Given opens and closings dilations,
erosions, this hit or
miss transform that I was talking
about that pulls out the shape.
You can then do further things, okay?
Here's a list of them.
Boundary, region, extracting connected
components, convex hull, thinning,
skeletons, pruning.
I'm just going to talk about two,
and I'm really just going to
talk about one in detail.
Not even detail, one slide's worth.
And then thinning,
I'll just mention, okay?
So sometimes,
you like to extract the boundary.
Well actually, that's very easy to do.
What I can do is, I can take an object.
If A plus B is the dilation, and
A minus B is the erosion, I can get the
boundary by just taking the object and
subtracting out
the eroded version of it.
Here, they talk about B
being a 3 by 3 square,
it could be whatever size square.
I'm going to take the binary pixels, and
I'm going to remove any of the ones that
survive the erosion process, all right?
So you want to do that, and voila.
This is what you get.
And you realize,
what's happening here of course,
is here's our original binary image.
And when I erode the, you know, the
contour moves in by a certain amount.
And if it's three by three by at
least one and a half, two pixels, so
what that'll do is, if I subtract what's
inside the red from the whole thing,
I end up with just this boundary.
So, it's just a trivial operation right?
I, I take the image, erode it, and then
subtract those pixels, and by subtract,
I mean remove those
pixels from the original.
And that's how you do boundaries.
There's another operation
called thinning.
You'll, you'll notice
this operator here.
This is this hit or miss operator.
What matters is,
you take your original picture and
you've got these different
structuring elements.
And essentially, you keep eating away
a at your picture using that structure,
that structuring elements, and
you would go from this filled in picture
like this, you would end up with,
with something that's just like this.
Or it's a one Ppxel wide thin band,
all right?
When you keep doing the thinning, and
that can be used for finding skeletons.
There used to be a lot of thought
about using skeletons for
a variety of shape representations
when we're doing models, and
people still use it and
that's why I mention it.
But I'm not going to talk,
anymore about it.
It's just thinning and thickening.
And in fact, the thickening
is just the inverse of that.
So here you have this original thing,
and then you're
growing it out till you get out towards
the, the boundary of some sort.
Again, I'm not going to worry
too much about the details.